okay thank you for sticking around so
late
um i'm going to talk can you can you
read my writing
so i'm going to talk about an old
problem in kuchelev it's nissan i think
it's
in the first five pages a couple of
problems in the first five pages
and this is joint work with mika goose
and tom watson
so we'll start with a two-party function
communication function capital f and
you know it has its associated communic
boolean it's a boolean function it has
its associated communication matrix
and chi 1 f
is the minimum number
of disjoint
monochromatic rectangles
it covers all the ones of the function
and chi 0 is the same thing but a
covering of the zeros
and chi which is the partition number
of the function f is the sum of these
two
okay so it's just you want to partition
this
0 1 matrix
into the smallest number of
monochromatic pieces okay and that's
called the partition number
and if you have a deterministic protocol
for this function
it induces a partition and the question
is whether these two
are the same so in particular the
the question is so it's clear that
if the deterministic communication
complexity of f
um is which way do i want this
is bigger than or equal to the log
of the partition number and we also know
that it's bounded on this side
by the log
squared of the partition number
and then the question is whether you
know which which direction is the right
one
okay and it was known
that um that the determinist the
communication complexity
is at least as large as two times the
log of the partition number
and that's in a result by i think kucha
levitz lineal and ostrovsky
i think he doesn't know so it's okay
and what i want to show you today is
that
that this is closer to the right answer
so
the deterministic communication
complexity of f
is bigger than or equal to is equal
yeah yep there exists
f certainly yeah i could just have an
all one matrix and then it would be
really easy
and um so that's the first thing and
then i'll also show you
that um we can get do better if we oh
what did i do here sorry nobody said
anything nice
so i meant to say that so the
deterministic communication complexity
suppressing a log factors log log
factors i guess it's at least as big
as the log of the partition number to
the 1.5
and if we look at chi 1 instead
then we get
the square and this is tight because
actually this
result here it really holds for chi one
not just for chi
okay and that's this is easy to see
but i won't do it today okay um
sorry thank you okay um
so just a few little things i wanted to
mention
so so applications are consequences um
so this is just uh we're getting you
know
first time we've gotten a you know a
better than linear
lower bound and i don't know what the
right answer is i don't know if it's 1.5
or two we've
i've thought about it and that's still
open but i wanted to tell you a little
bit about this so this question
also this statement
um yeah i guess you can just look at the
the negation
oh this is because i'm taking logs yeah
but that's
even no i'm saying so if you have the
lower
the thing below
yeah you'll see yeah you'll see yeah
okay so first of all this question i
don't understand so why could you apply
it to kai zero
so one of kai
in general has to be exist stuff
otherwise it doesn't make sense
is that okay okay so so
one consequence and this is really not a
consequence it's like another way to
state the same thing
um yana caucus studied this clique
independent set problem
and this is a communication problem
where one you have an underlying graph
that the players both know and one
player is given an independent set of
the graph and the other player is given
a clique and they want to know whether
they have a vertex in common
and this problem is
it's it's basically complete for for
these kinds of protocols
protocols so non-deterministic protocols
where there's a unique witness
because obviously if you have a clique
and a coke leak that intersect they can
only intersect in one vertex
okay so this problem is complete and so
you get this tight result for yana
caucus's problem
okay and before this it was known uh
quite recently actually
mika proved a lower bound um
for this for this problem therefore and
also this problem and i think it's
something like 1.1
kaiwana so we weren't the first people
to so this was the first result that did
better than
they got something non-trivial for the
problem this is a little bit
incomparable because he actually proved
it for co-non-determinist
so his lower bound is not it's not just
a deterministic bond it's a
co-non-deterministic lower bound so it's
a bad
it's it's a bound for a stronger
communication model but the
the you know the numbers are not as good
um his proof
is uh so our proof is easy really easy
in one sense and
and more and more difficult in another
sense and i'll tell you that in a minute
and secondly we get a new lower bound
for the log rank conjecture
and this is just because um so the
deterministic communication complexity
is at least as big as
make sure i get my directions right
so if you have there's a log do you know
what the log to the log rank conjecture
is the conjecture that
that the deterministic communication for
any function f
that the deterministic communication
complexity of the
function f is more or less equal to
the log of the rank over the reals of f
raised to some polynomial okay
so it's a beautiful conjecture and it's
stating that basically for any boolean
function f if you want to understand its
deterministic complexity
all you have to do is understand know
what its rank is okay
that they're within a polynomial factor
of one another it's a long
it's a long-standing open problem and
most people have been working on upper
bounds and the best upper bound
is something like by shahar love it it's
something like square root of the rank
with some log factors and what we get is
a
is a lower bound that um
okay and this is easy it just follows
because
yeah all of this is exactly yeah and and
this is just easy this is just because
if you have
you know if you have a deterministic
protocol
you have it however many
the monochromatic one rectangles um
that's
the rank of the matrix is at most the
number of monochromatic one rectangles
which is
chi one okay so our our quadratic
separation between deterministic
complexity
and log of chi 1 of x gives us okay
and before the best that was known i
think was
something like 1.26
yeah so so i said that but just briefly
the upper bound holds for clive f that
also hurts for chi 1 of f and it's it's
really just a it's a
it's a divide and conquer algorithm you
look at the degree of
the clique you find a vertex of degree
yeah it's a it's a binary search
so i want to give you some idea of how
this goes because it's surprising i
think
that the proof is actually pretty easy
um
and i'm going to give you a three-step
program for prove it
i'm going to prove hopefully both of
them but i'm going to mostly i'll start
with this one
and then we'll use that one to prove
this one
so i'm going to give you a three-step
program and
this is a program to prove communication
flexi lower bounds
and we really like it and if you're
having trouble with your
other programs and you're having
nightmares about shears and equality
and the chain rule you might want to try
this program
it incorporates elements of information
theory in it
and it can often be used when when other
approaches fail
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to work with
composed functions and i'm sure a lot of
you've seen this before by the way we're
not claiming that this is our method
so the communication complexity
functions that we're going to work with
are they're going to be a composition of
two functions f and g and i just want to
say that this general technique
it's been used in a lot of places not
just in communication complexity
so it's been used in communication
complexity all over the place
one notable example is is a lot of
surestuffs work
but there's lots of others it's really
behind a lot of the
work in extended formulations
it's behind like the monotone switching
network lower bounds
of potato i the list goes on it's
it's also comes up a lot in proof
complexity lower bounds
and the basic idea is if you work with
composed functions that your life is
much easier because you can study
the complexity of the outer function f
in much simpler models
and then lift it to to study the
complexity
of capital f in your stronger model okay
so we're going to look at composed
functions and f
is going to be a boolean function
yeah that's the outer function on n bits
and g
is going to be the inner function it's
some gadget
and in this talk g is going to be the
indexing function
so today and g is going to be the
indexing function
so alice is going to get
an index or a coordinate and bob's going
to get
a string
and g of you know a b
is going to be so a is going to point to
a location
in the m bit string b and they're going
to output
sorry they're going to output b sub a
okay so just the usual indexing function
and m
is going to be some polynomial in n
like say n to the 10th okay and then
capital f
on some input so
so take take x
y x in
x to the n and y in y to the n
so capital f of x y is just going to be
f applied to g of x 1 y
1 g of x 2 y y2
and so on
and like i said g is always going to be
the indexing function
and little f um i'll tell you about that
next
okay
okay so that's the first step to work to
work with composed functions and
and then we're gonna study
the query complexity which is a much
simpler
computational model
of the out of the outer function little
f okay so we're going to try to prove
our separation
in this much simpler query complexity
model okay and even if you don't know
what this is for now
i'll tell you what it is in a minute but
it's basically going to amount to
decision tree complexity
and more generally it's going to it's
going to be like a oracle version of
whatever complexity class we're talking
about
okay okay and then
like all k-step programs you have to
appeal to higher powers
and in our case it's roz mckenzie
so this is uh
get down here and write this so we want
to we want to lift
the result to the communication
complexity world
via a general transfer theorem
and this is going to be a theorem like i
said for us it's going to be ros
mckenzie but you can
use other higher powers if you want
there's there's several theorems of this
form
that are quite nice and depending on the
model you can use different ones
but we'll use the raz mechanic we're
going to have to modify the ros mckenzie
one
but let me just tell you what let me
just start with that so basically you
have a general theorem
that's going to allow you to take the
lower bound that you got here in the
query query complexity of the world
and basically lift it to get a lower
bound in the same model
for the communication complexity class
for the
for the composed function okay
so what's this theorem so this is the
ros mckenzie theorem
from a 99 paper and this is not how they
stated the result
they actually stated and proved it for a
more special case of this
where it was for c and f search problems
but
if you're brave enough to go through the
proof they actually prove this more
general theorem and
in our paper we simplified the proof
somewhat streamlined it
and um we think that it's much easier to
understand now it's given as an
algorithm
that takes you from a communication
complexity protocol
for the lifted composed function and
produces
a decision tree for the for the little f
okay
so the theorem states that for any f
and for the g that i mentioned the
decision tree complexity this is my
notation
for decision tree complexity of the
composed function
is equal to the sorry this should be
communication complexity of the composed
function is going to be equal to the
decision tree complexity
of the outer function times
some log n term okay
and this is this is basically inequality
okay
so this is saying that i'm sorry this is
where g equals index
this is for g equal to the index
function yeah
so what is this saying this is saying
that all you have to do is prove a
decision tree lower bound for f
and you automatically for free get the
same lower bound with this extra log
factor
for this composed function okay
now it's easy to see one direction if
you have a decision
tree for f then it's easy to see that
you can get
a communication complexity protocol for
this the players just follow the
decision tree
and since alice's input is
small of length log m which is order log
n
anytime they want to decide you know the
value
of one of these meta variables you know
alice just sends her order log
n bits to bob and he figure you know he
sends back the index value
okay so that's the easy direction and
the hard direction is the basically the
theorem
that you can go the other way around
that you can take a communication
complexity protocol
for the composed function and you can
extract from it a decision tree
and uh you know the complexity of the
decision tree is this divided by login
so i won't be able to tell you much
about this proof of this today
but it's really nice and really not bad
it's been it's very natural and it does
use concepts information theoretic
concepts
but i'll show you how we can use this
theorem
so use the theorem to at least prove you
know maybe maybe
they're both quite easy once you have
this okay
oh you need another idea you need to
prove the query separation so let me
just state
the uh the query versions of the theorem
so theorem one prime this is the simpler
query version of the theorem that we
ultimately want
so this theorem states that the decision
tree complexity
of there exists enough
so that the decision tree complexity of
f is
omega so bear with me i'll tell you what
this is in a minute this is more or less
i'll i'll explain these in a minute
okay so this side is clear this is the
decision tree complexity of f
and on this side is the query analog of
of log of chi 1 of f okay what is what
is this
u p stands for unique p so this is
uh in the non-relativized world
this is the class unique piece so you
you have a
non-deterministic it's the complexity of
a non-deterministic
you know turing machine that where the
witnesses are unique
and this 2up is uh is where the yes
instances are unique and the no
instances are unique so the decision
tree version of it
um is you want to rewrite f
as the disjunction of a bunch of
terms and each term ti so if if the u p
decision tree complexity of f is is at
most k
then that means you can rewrite f as a
disjunction of terms
for each of these terms has size at most
k and
for every one of the function
there exists a unique
ti so that ti of alphas is one
okay that makes sense so this i hope
this is the
this should look like the natural query
analog of the class
u p and two u p is like i said the same
thing but you have it for the
for the the ones and for the zeros okay
um the size of ti is the is basically
the
um the decision tree complexity in this
model
says how many bits you have to look at
to have a witness and you want the
witnesses to be unique
okay so now i want to try to show you
how how to prove
we'll do we'll do this one first okay
anybody have any questions
so i wanted to say one thing um
so this one of these two i forget which
one let's see
so this one this one here
there was a weaker version of this
result that was actually already known
by sofitsky and i think he got like
something like one point uh 1.26
so so you can get something here without
doing you know
just applying his query complexity
separation to our modified version of
raz mckenzie but i'm going to show you
uh you know
an easier and better bound construction
yeah so with the modified roz mckenzie
in the suvitsky result
you get yeah
okay so
so i want to do this one this is the
main one and then this one is
this one is easy once you have this but
you just take the and of a bunch of
copies of this one
to get this one okay and the numbers
degrade because we're taking the and
so we want to come up with
boolean function f where the decision
tree complexity
is going to be about um
k and the u p decision tree complexity
is going to
be about k squared so
so oh sorry yes thank you
no you're right you're right it should
be this way
okay so let's start with a warm-up this
is
we're going to look at a function f
on k squared boolean variables
and it's just a 0 1 matrix and we want
to output
1 so we want to say yes on a zero one
filling in of this matrix
if and only if there exists a unique
column of all ones
okay so if you have a column
exactly one column that's entirely
filled with ones and no other column has
all ones then we want to say
that we want to say one so this
separates
p from np okay so the what are the what
do the witnesses look like
well we have to um you know find
the column that has all the ones in it
that's that's k bits and then for all
the other columns we have to identify
a zero somewhere okay
so that's roughly uh you know that's
like roughly 2k
i said k but okay now this is not in up
because um i'll tell we'll get to the
lower bound in a minute
but it's not in up because these zero
witnesses don't are not necessarily
unique
okay so we have to fix it up and why is
its decision tree complexity k
squared well the adversary so when
you're
proving the lower bound you just you get
to pick the direction
you know given any decision tree the
adversary gets to pick the direction to
walk in
and so what's the obviously going to do
no matter what's queried um
we're just going to always say one until
we get to the last place in the column
and then we'll say zero
and we just keep doing that so it's
going to take basically you're going to
force the person to
look at all k squared things okay and so
how do we fix this up
so that the queries are unique
i'm not the queries so that the so that
the yes instances are unique
so the way we'll fix it up
so we're going to have a matrix again
and each instead of having just one
boolean value
per entry of the matrix we're going to
have two values
we're going to have a zero or one value
in the upper part
so for example here
then the lower part is going to be a
pointer to some other location in the
matrix
okay so for example here we might point
to this one you probably see where this
is going
i'll point to here
okay and we're going to output one
so if and only if how do i say this
so basically you want to you want there
to be
like before you want there to be a
unique column of all ones
okay and you're going to
find so one thing i didn't say these can
be pointers to other locations
or they can be bottom okay so the
so each entry of the matrix is labeled
with a pair where the first element in
the pair is 0 or 1 and the second
element in the pair
is a log k number union with bottom so
it either points to another location in
the matrix
or its bottom okay and
so what you want to do is you want to
find if it's a one instance you want to
find the all one column
and then make sure it's all one and then
the very fir
we know we want it to be unique so the
very first place
uh in this column that's not a bottom
in this case it's here you want to
follow that pointer
okay and and then you want to follow it
and to get to a place that's the zero
then that goes to another place that's a
zero and so on
does that make sense so it's a unique so
by doing this following the pointer
we're going to get to unique zeros
places in all the other columns
okay so a unique yes instance is exactly
that
it's a column of all ones together with
you
take the pointer that's the first
pointer in this column
that's non-null you follow it that has
to be a zero
follow it that has to be zero and so on
and you
you follow it n minus k minus one times
and you should cover
all of the columns and you should see
that they're all zeros
does that make sense
it doesn't have to be it can be here you
just
you know but it's the point is it's the
number of
matrix entries that you have to look at
to verify that it's a one instance is
is about 2k again okay because you're
you check that all these are one and
then you have to
no i'm not constraining it to be all the
way at the bottom yeah
okay so that's that's basically the
the function and then to check that it
that it
am i over am i okay do i have another
couple minutes
so to check that this um has determines
the complexity k squared
um it's really just sort of the obvious
adversary strategy
you you know as long as you ask
about a location you answer with one as
long as you can
and you say bottom as long as you can
and when you get to the very
last one you say zero and bottom okay
and you're basically filling in columns
with all ones and then one zero and then
we have to figure out how to do the
pointers
so you basically want to do the pointers
in reverse order
so the very first column where you
filled it in with all ones and a zero
okay that's like the first the first one
that happens then you look at the next
the next one that gets filled in that
way and that one that that zero
that the last one that zero gets pointed
to the to the previous one
and so on does that make sense
so in that way you're basically forcing
k squared k
squared spots to be to be looked at and
you know this is not boolean anymore or
if it is boolean these have size like
order log n
but that's why i was suppressing the the
logs that make sense
so that's how you get this separation
and then like i said this one
you just take the and of
you know k independent copies of this
and
you can check that the in that case the
the the witnesses
will be unique and will have length now
k squared because you have to have wit
yes yes witnesses for each one and
you can also check that the uh
that if it's a no instance that you have
to check k k cubed you more or less have
to check everything
and i think that's all i have to say
oh you mean why why it is
steven you want to understand why why
chi one
uh corresponds to this class yeah so
this is so if you think about a chi one
is just
um you're just looking at
non-deterministic protocols
where the witnesses have to be have to
be unique
so like if you think about a
communication protocol as they make a
guess
and then and then they check to see if
the guess is right
the chi one is sort of measuring the
unique one and
and yeah this is like the query version
of that
i had a question seem to
assume that when you query a monitor
yeah i'm just giving away for free in
the lower bound i'm giving it away for
free
so as soon as you query one bit i'll
give all log i'll give away all logs so
that's why we lose
thanks